in exile for decades these palestinian
refugees have long lived on the margins
of society
they are among the most vulnerable and
poorest communities in lebanon their
situation has been made worse because
the economy is close to collapse
and now their lifeline faces a shortage
of funds
the financial crisis of unrwa has been
of an existential nature
and it's of an existential nature
because we cannot properly deliver our
services anymore at the time the needs
intercom have significantly increased
providing access to education to all the
palestinian refugees girls and boys in
the camp and in the country we are
providing assistance to more than 200
000 people we are providing primary
health care
lebanon's currency crash has hurt the
palestinians as well inflation led to
food prices increasing by tenfold
people are just buying the basics they
no longer buy in kilos but in grams
for many help from the u.n is vital
especially since the lebanese state
denies palestinians basic services
umrah provides education and medicine
but they should give us more help
because many people can afford to buy
bread
a recent decision by the lebanese
authorities to expand palestinian rights
in the labor market is welcomed here as
a way to deal with rising unemployment
but many tell us it's limited and what
is needed is to grant them basic rights
i can't register my truck under my name
i can't even get a license to drive it
there are minimum rights which
palestinians don't have we thank the
minister for the new decree but i doubt
it will resolve unemployment
palestinians have faced what rights
groups call discriminatory policies
since they first arrived in lebanon in
1948.
successive governments believe easing
restrictions and providing them
citizenship will encourage them to
settle here permanently that's why the
majority rely on the informal labor
market but opportunities are drying up
if we don't work we can't eat and there
isn't much work nowadays because of the
economic crisis
even before the economic collapse
lebanon's palestinians were struggling
it has since pushed more into poverty
the united nations says it now has to
find money so that the crisis won't have
what it calls a devastating humanitarian
impact senator al jazeera beirut